elon musk isn't known to keep his
opinions to himself we say warren
buffett for example
andrea totally frank i'm not his biggest
fan that was on joe brogan's podcast
last year and later he cast out on
buffett's public image when asked by the
new york times whether buffett was
overrated saying that the grandfatherly
figure is maybe overstating the case for
buffett's part he's been a bit tamer
when speaking about musk what do you
think of elon musk though if you met him
and would you invest in tesla
well i think you're trying to bait me
the two men are similar in the sense
that they're filthy rich musk's net
worth is 190 billion dollars buffets is
over a hundred billion but dig a little
deeper and you'll see they're two very
different kinds of billionaires
warren buffett is widely considered the
greatest investor of all time he's the
chairman and ceo of berkshire hathaway a
holding company that has consistently
given its shareholders returns of around
20
every year that's without heavily
investing in tech companies and would
you invest in tesla no
okay he's largely avoided tech companies
because he famously said he doesn't
understand them well enough so it's hard
to estimate their future value he
admitted he messed up by now buying
shares in google and amazon years ago
and instead of picking individual stocks
to buy buffett favors index funds like
the s p 500 a preset basket of stocks
that offers more safety and diversity
buffett prefers playing it safe by
choosing low risk investments his
strategy is to buy and hold for decades
and that's the fundamental difference
between him and musk musk is high risk
high reward with the potential for very
high losses too after making 180 million
when the online bank he ran became
paypal which was then bought by ebay he
sunk all of the profits into three
companies if things had gone south musk
would have been left with nothing but it
was a risk he was willing to take
buffett tries to protect his
shareholders from as much risk as
possible he prefers investing in
companies that have large moats not
unlike olden day castles that had a
ditch filled with water encircling them
for protection in the economic world a
moat protects the company from the
competition by having some sort of
advantage such as being able to produce
at a lower cost due to cheaper access to
raw materials musk doesn't think this is
the best strategy he said if your only
defense against invading armies is emote
you will not last long instead what
matters is the pace of innovation in his
case that means rapidly building
starships and scaling up the production
of teslas in response buffett defended
the idea of moats saying elon may turn
things upside down in some areas i don't
think you'd want to take us on in candy
referring to berkshire hathaway's
investment in suites it owns american
manufacturer sees candies that prompted
some cheeky tweets from musk then i'm
going to build a moat and fill it with
candy warren b will not be able to
resist investing berkshire hathaway
kryptonite and that wasn't the end of
his tweets over sweets i'm starting a
candy company and it's going to be
amazing i'm super super serious fair to
say musk is not actually serious about
starting a candy company however he and
buffett are directly competing against
each other berkshire hathaway is gaining
a foothold in the growing electric
vehicle market over a decade ago
buffett's business partner charlie
munger convinced him to pick up an
obscure chinese automaker byd build your
dreams is a competitor to tesla for his
part musk is poised to take on the car
insurance industry where buffett is
heavily invested in a previous video i
talked about how tesla plans to start
selling personal car insurance in more
u.s states with musk predicting that it
could one day account for a third of
tesla's business that would put tesla on
a collision course with berkshire
hathaway about a third of its business
is in insurance including geico buffett
brushes off any sense of threat once
remarking i bet against any company in
the auto business getting into insurance
on rogan's podcast musk said he felt
there were two different kinds of
billionaires who shouldn't be seen as
one and the same those who got rich from
engineering and designing a product and
those who made an incredible amount of
money playing the stock market though
that seems like a harsh assessment musk
did add that he does see value in what
buffett does he used the example of
trying to figure out whether to invest
in coca-cola or pepsi musk said it was a
boring job to decide which one deserves
more capital but ultimately an important
job and speaking of coke it just happens
to be one of buffett's favorite
investments and soft drinks he downs up
to five cans a day including one that he
has every morning with his three dollar
and change mcdonald's breakfast buffett
is known for living very frugally the
oracle of omaha still lives in the same
house in omaha that he purchased in 1958
for 31 500. musk lives well below his
means too he's been known to camp out at
tesla's factories when the going has
gotten tough and his main residence in
boca chica in south texas is said to be
a house valued at just 50 000 they also
have something else in common they
pledge to give away most of their
fortune in the case of musk he's
promised to give away half on earth and
half on mars to build a city there if
you want to stay up to date on the
latest news about elon musk and his
companies or warren buffett and his
investments you can sign up for a free
newsletter morning brew which sponsored
this video that's where i learned about
musk's recent tiff with apple and the
interesting comments he made about apple
during tesla's second quarter earnings
call what i really like about
morningbrew is that it's quick and easy
to read it only takes about five minutes
and then you're up to date on the latest
business and tech news and again
morningbrew is completely free all you
have to do is enter your email and
you're good to go you can sign up by
using my custom link in the description
for newsthink i'm cindy palm
[Music]
you